où va le royaume uni après bientôt trois
ans en poste de premier ministre une
chose tonnes a donc fini par lâcher la
faire c'était le 7 juillet dernier il
était acculé par les scandales qui ont
éclaboussé son verre devant bien qu
l'est aussi par son propre camp beaucoup
ne voulait plus le voir en peinture
alors depuis l'incertitude règne les
militantes horizon est appelée à
trancher la question du successeur dans
une primaire interne où tous les coups
semblent permis ce que nous raconte
marion vivre regarde
aussi les visages des candidats à la
succession de boris johnson et c'est ce
mercredi que les députés conservateurs
révéleront les noms des deux finalistes
c'est donc une semaine décisive qui
s'ouvre en grande-bretagne et la tension
monte d'un cran à l'image des échanges
tendus dimanche lors du débat télévisé
l'inflation est l'ennemi qui rend pauvre
tout le monde richie tu as fait
augmenter les textes haut niveau le plus
haut en sept ans pour le moment ces
riches isna que l'ex ministre des
finances qui fait figure de favori c'est
le candidat le plus assuré celui qui a
été chancelier de l'échiquier depuis
longtemps inquiet le plus professionnel
à et qui passent le mieux par mais parmi
les députés et peut-être aussi par mais
dans l'opinion publique britannique dans
son ensemble face à lui deux autres
candidats de se démarque lice trust la
chef de la diplomatie et penny mordaunt
la secrétaire d'état au commerce
tout l'enjeu pour le parti conservateur
est temps de choisir le meilleur
candidat pour rester majoritaire au
parlement après 12 ans de présence un
peu l'impression que c'est une partie
qui est usée par tout ce temps au
pouvoir par tous était pas
à l la question pour le parti
conservateur c est ce qu ils choisissent
la nouveauté au risque de trouver avec
quelques se retrouver avec quelqu'un qui
n'a pas les épaules pour le travail ou
esquivant avec l'expérience au risque de
se voir a reproché d'être dans la
continuité des années folles
les deux finalistes seront départagés à
la fin de l'été cette fois-ci par les
membres du parti conservateur
le nom du futur premier ministre sera
lui connu le 5 septembre
où va le royaume uni on en parle ce soit
avec mes invités bonsoir sylvie bermann
serait une habituée de ce plateau de
sens public vous êtes diplomate et vous
êtes une fine connaisseuse du royaume
uni puisque vous avez été ambassadrice
de france à londres de 2014 à 2017 vous
avez publié l'an dernier goodbye
britannia le royaume uni au défi du bric
site chez stock bonsoir philippe turn
bons soins vous êtes britannique
journaliste pour la chaîne france 24
c'est exact bienvenue dans cette
émission bonsoir patrick martin genevois
figure habitués enseignant à sciences po
paris vous êtes un spécialiste des
questions européennes on le sait vous
avez publié récemment vers une sixième
république ou comment refonder la
démocratie française aux éditions
studyrama et puis bien sûr hyundai qui
est resté avec moi jusqu'à la fin de
cette émission avant de parler d'avenir
où va le royaume uni je voudrais quand
même qu'on revienne sur les conditions
du départ de boris johnson avec vous
philippe terme parce que beaucoup
croyaient que boris johnson ne
démissionnerait jamais et beaucoup
redoutent qu'ils s'accrochent encore à
son poste et premier séjour figure moi
même parce que on s'est posé la question
comment ça va se terminer parce que
bolton semble comprendre à une seule
envie c'est d'un premier ministre et ce
pour lui c'était la réussite de sa vie
tout ce qui va avec le fait qu'il doit
travailler as you et l'euro le premier
ministre pour lui c'est de deuxième
importance le plus important c'est le
fait qu'il soit premier ministre qui
soit un peu comme winston churchill son
idole d'ailleurs il a écrit un livre
sur winston churchill et on voit même
dans quelques-uns de ses sorties une
imitation clic pendant la voit dans les
attitudes manière
de win situation donc il voulait
absolument s'accrocher à ce poste et la
constitution britannique n'est pas
écrite c'est plutôt basées sur le bon
vouloir des personnes à savoir c'est un
comédien gentleman's agreement en
anglais l'accord entre gentleman ont
fait la bonne chose au bon moment dans
l'intérêt et du parti et du pays bien
évidement dont quatre parutions se
noyant dans du territoire en plus
prompts insolite à savoir que lui tu
t'es pour lui même et le pays et le
parti est en deuxième position et ont
donc en savait pas si la lie missionné
et philippe ça veut dire qu'il ya pas
une ligne de texte qui dit on n'a jamais
eu une situation telle qu'elle en grande
bretagne oui il ya des leviers qui
peuvent être mises en route pour le
faire partir mais c'est assez compliqué
et donc c'était seulement après tout ces
démissions cascade des membres de son
parti du gouvernement
qui ont quelque part force évolutions
sont à portée mais je pense que jusqu'à
la dernier mérite on se dit mais est-ce
qu'on va pas se trouver en situation
comme on a connu aux états unis 6
janvier 2021 ou comme dans la fusée
devait partir il allait lancer ma une
nappe elle allait se manifester devant
la chambre des communes on n'est pas
arrivé mais mais la question était posée
patrick martin genêt il vous paraît
juste ce parallèle avec donald trump
disons que il a tout fait pour rester au
temps d'antenne street est évident
certains le soupçonnaient de vouloir
trouver une solution pourrait
s'éterniser en disait qu il n'était plus
possible qu'ils se maintiennent
haute-engadine street on ne parle plus
de motion de censure cet après midi à la
chambre des communes était discuté d'une
motion de censure initiée par le parti
travailliste je ne pense pas que ça ira
jusqu'au bout je ne vois pas boris
johnson sollicité une marche contre la
chambre des communes jeu ce n'est pas
dans l'esprit britannique mais on le
soupçonne de tout faire pour savonner la
planche de son successeur est d'ailleurs
récemment on a appris dans la presse
qu'ils s'apprêtaient à nommer deux pères
deux membres de la chambre des lords de
telle façon que ça obligerait à des
élections partielles de son successeur
sous-entendu il perdra où elle perdra
ces élections partielles et le premier
ou la première ministre sera obligé de
dissoudre la chambre des communes alors
qu'on a vu hier dans le débat qu'aucun
des candidats ne souhaitait aller à des
élections législatives anticipées
sylvie vous vous l'avez connu johnson
quand il était maire de l'ombre est-ce
que vous pouvez nous raconter un peu que
l homme est il de votre souvenir et puis
après sur son avenir politique vous
reposerez une autre question à quand il
était maire de londres c'était quelqu'un
d'extrêmement sympathique excentrique
qui aiment et séduire et qui étaient
souvent dans la provocation cela dit à
l'époque il n'était pas du tout
exceet heures puisqu'ils défendent est
au contraire l'immigration est une ville
ouverte moi j'ai rencontré une semaine
après mon arrivée dans un petit déjeuner
débat il expliquait que athènes avait
survécu contrairement à sparte parce que
c'était une ville ouverte donc
effectivement comme ça a été dit ce qui
l'intéresse c'est lui même et c'était
d'être premier ministre alors au moment
des débats sur les conséquences
économiques du du bric site amber rhodes
qui était je crois ministre de l'énergie
à ce moment là lui a dit toute façon il
ya un seul chiffre qui intéresse boris
c'est nombreux ten c'est-à-dire
l'adresse de tarnac street et le fait
d'être premier ministre et comme vous
l'avez dit effectivement le travail qui
allait avec ce n'était pas tellement de
sujets il a d'ailleurs accepté un
un accord qui faisait passer la
frontière
entre le royaume uni et l'irlande du
nord lors que le theresa may avait dit
que jamais aucun premier ministre
n'accepte rsa puis ensuite il l'a
dénoncé il a passé sa vie à mentir il a
commencé en étant renvoyé par son
premier journal le times for intérieur
une fausse interview une fausse citation
il a passé son temps à inventer des
choses sur l'union européenne qui
faisait rire sauf a été correspondant à
moins 5
oui on soumet les bananes est la
courbure des malades enfin c'est pas la
stature adoré ce afin qu'en télé devenue
mais oui mais parce que tout le monde
rit y est mais ce qu'on dit les
journalistes ils ont dit on s'est trompé
c'est à dire on se dit c'est du boris
était un peu agaçant mais c'était drôle
en fait ce n'était pas drôle parce que
ça à préparer l'opinion publique à la
détestation de l'union européenne et du
du bric site est alors quand on parle
effectivement de la comparaison avec
train faut se rappeler quand même que
l'équipe de joe biden l'a appelé le
minitre up et que john sopel qui est le
correspondant de la bbc à washington qui
a écrit un livre sur sur trump a dit que
le refus de boris johnson en tout cas le
fait qu'ils s'accrochaient c'était le
moment capitole de boris johnson donc il
n'est pas allé jusque là mais on a bien
vu dans sa déclaration
vous n'y a même pas prononcer le terme
de débats et il a jugé excentrique le
fait que les parlementaires décident de
choisir un nouveau dirigeant alors on va
bien évidemment parler du site mais
parce qu'on se pose la question pourquoi
pour les sciences ne peut pas
démissionner pourquoi il refuse de
partir maintenant parce que non à menton
normal donc l on n'est pas du tout une
grande bretagne un premier ministre
évincé démissionne et il y a son adjoint
sont députés qui prend la place jusqu'à
la nomination de l'élection d'une
nouvelle chute à partie par les cow boys
smith s'accroche au pouvoir et il veut à
la fin du mois de juillet fêter les
noces avec sa femme karine il veut le
faire dans la résidence du premier
ministre à tchekhov et il ya beaucoup de
l'interview en bretagne de journalistes
gens qu'ils connaissent en nylon et
simple que pollution qui ne veut pas
partir parce que s'il part maintenant il
peut pas fait elle ne comprend pas que
ce premier ministre
40 60 ministres ont démissionné puisse
encore se maintenir au terme d'un débat
certains considèrent qu'il est devenu
toxique et même dangereux et aujourd'hui
on dirait qu'il peut se maintenir au
teint d'un ex trith jusqu'au mois de
septembre n'y at il pas une alternative
publié un premier ministre pas rater
alors oui s'il ya une vo de défiance
vis-à-vis du gouvernement là il faut
qu'il parte il y aura des élections
législatives en grande bretagne le
problème c'est que la lune serait quand
même ça oui le problème c'est que le
parti travailliste quitteront face ne
l'a pas demandée jusqu'à maintenant
d'ailleurs là ils sont en train de le
faire parce qu'ils avaient peur de
perdre les élections et parce que le
parti conservateur sud pour l'édition
sne est resté populaire avec une grosse
majorité de 81 sièges et on fasse ce qui
est en ma le patron du parti
travailliste a eu beaucoup de mal à se
faire une image populaire auprès de deux
électorats sont tus parce qu'il fascine
presse de droite qui est extrêmement
acharnée contre la gauche
à chialer contre toute personne qui
critique pour le sturm sonne et qui très
lus ou en grande bretagne lisez moi mais
du parti travailliste est au sein du
parti conservateur que cette affaire
doit être réglé on parle de ce fameux
comité 1922 qui ce puissant comité des
députés de base du parti et se poser la
question de ce que le comité 1922
pourrait être exigé la démission
immédiate de bruit johnson est
aujourd'hui semble-t-il on entend dire
ce qu'il ne fait pas juste on va parler
du vrai que si bien sûr on va parler
j'aurais juste avoir deux trois mots sur
le bilan bruce johnson est ce qu'il a
été un bon horrible premier ministre à
leicester quand même qui fut conseiller
de tony blair écrit cette semaine dans
l'express que boris johnson fut le site
le premier nice le plus malhonnêtes le
plus corrompu le plus incompétent et le
plus déshonoré de notre histoire vous
êtes d'accord avec ça c'est pas un peu
beaucoup je suis d'accord avec ça je
veux pas venir ici pour faire du buzz
bashing parce que moins souvent
dit deux autres plateaux n'y allez pas
mais bon il ya sept chiffres qui vous
regardent plein les yeux on y z'ont qu'
on est dans une situation quand même
très inquiétant concombres et les
engagements 180 millions est vraiment le
coc vite c'est le plus gros chiffre et
38 de plus qu'en france depuis le début
du conte vide parce que porsche n'a pas
pris l'initiative au début de fait le
confinement disons non je continue à
serrer les mains jeu continuera d auzon
fallait avoir les matchs de foot et il a
loupé je sais plus combien de réunions
d'urgence et de son équipe qui gérait la
réponse qu vide parce qu'ils voulaient
préparer les noces avec cary sa future
femme l annonce du fait qu'elle allait
avoir un enfant et donc il part à l'est
et donc les décisions ont été prises à
la hâte aux catastrophes mais pas en
amont commune où il fallut faire donc ça
c'est le premier chip deuxièmement ils
sont bons avec une inflation galopante
qui pourrait arriver jusqu'à 12% s'il
existait une activation grande bretagne
et une bonne partie après la dépend de
la grande bretagne de l'union européenne
se trouve plus pauvres aujourd'hui et
qui se rend compte que finalement ils
ont été lésés saut ce qui était bon pour
au brésil on parler d'inflation record
de croissance en berne sur le plan
économique il ya quelque chose à sauver
dans le bilan de bruce johnson patrick
maintenant je vais écouter certains
disaient que la croissance
allait repartir et des traits il est
très fier de son bilan il a encore fait
une intervention cette réponse cet
après-midi en disant qu'il laissait
l'économie dans un état parfait d'après
de vue libéral mais naturellement c'est
une auto satisfaction est ce qu'il ya
des choses à sauver bien sûr la city
reste la city je pense que jamais
londres ne pourra est une place
financière mineurs bien sûr mais disons
que le bric site à entraîner quand même
des conséquences très importantes
on a parlé d' inflation parce que avec
la démission diminution de la livre cela
a entraîné quand même une augmentation
des prix et on voit bien aujourd'hui que
le patronat britannique est très inquiet
au moment précisément où la ministre 10
trusts qui est partie du quai qui est
donc candidate veut déposer à et a
déposé un projet de loi pour démolir
détricoter les accords sur la langue du
nord qui permet donc les flux
commerciaux entre l'irlande et la
grande-bretagne donc on n'est pas encore
sorti d'affaires de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive je pense que la situation
sera extrêmement difficile pour le
successeur est naturellement outre le
bruch site il ya aussi cette question de
l'augmentation des impôts qu'on reproche
à michel d'acs sur le plan de la
politique extérieure et de la place du
royaume uni dans le monde là c'est la
catastrophe
je pense qu'ils ont un petit peu disparu
c'est à dire que boris johnson parlait
de globo britten une
grande-bretagne planétaire qui passerait
par dessus l'europe qui étaient censés
l'empêcher d'avoir des relations avec le
reste du monde sauf que il a perdu ses
relations avec les européens il n'a pas
gagné pour autant des relations
évidemment pas avec les chinois encore
mois avec les russes donc c'est
difficile de parler d'un royaume uni
planétaire
c'est ce qui est très frappant c'est que
aujourd'hui quand on parle de l'avenir
du monde on parle bien sûr des états
unis de la chine bon à cause de la
garonne ukraine évidemment la russie
redevient un acteur on parle de l'union
européenne mais pas deux pas du royaume
uni donc je pense que tout cela était
une illusion dès le départ et sur le
plan des relations entre l'angleterre et
les autres composantes de la couronne
les relations tendues avec lycos et
clerlande alors on commence avec les
relents du nord
le problème avec le protocole alors pour
expliquer ce que c'est les relents du
nord fait partie du royaume uni mais
elle la frontière avec la république
irlandaise qui toujours dans l'union
européenne à locales et aux mondiaux on
lit plus donc il faut mettre ce front de
fait quelques pas honte pas le remettre
à l'endroit où ils devaient y est à
savon entre les longs du nom et la
république irlandaise parce que c'était
là où il y avait le tout les problèmes
de guerre civile qu'on a connue pendant
plus de 30 ans qui ont été terminés avec
la cour de vendredi saint et le fait que
les frontières n'existent plus donc pour
lui a dit que jamais mais très
affrontiez dont la mère lombez dès qu'il
est élu il a fait et il a signé le
protocole avec l'union européenne
sachant très bien que ce protocole était
inapplicable parce qu a pas de solution
qui peut être trouvée pour sauver les
rangs d'une eau de la situation dans
laquelle ils se trouvent actuellement il
faut mettre le la frontière quelque part
maintenant la frontière se trouve grosso
modo dans la mère irlandaise donc tous
les produits qui viennent de
grande-bretagne qui porte son nez rond
d'une eau doit passer par la douane ou
avoir des impôts dessus parce qu'il n'y
a pas de frontière avec la région elle
est une européenne donc tout ça suffit
vraiment énervé les loyalistes on est au
long d'une eau qui se soude lésés par
rapport à ce qu'on avait promis les lois
lycée ceux qui sont les airs long des
pros grande bretagne ne saurai donc là
il ya un gros problème réglé
polichinelle n'a pas n'a pas trouvé de
solution et avec les causses
il ya de plus en plus de demandes donné
que le stade dumas premier ministre
écossais sous une deuxième référendum
pour le moment l'on doit donner son
accord aux pollutions sont toujours
refusé en disant vous avez une référence
de monde 2014 vous avez voté pour rester
un parti de du royaume uni c'est pas
demain que vous aurez une deuxième
référendum ce qu'on risque c'est que les
causses fasse un référendum défi de
londres pour des deux tubes manière on
ne demande plus la couronne on va
demander aux gens de voter oui ou non
puisqu'il enseigne l'éthique cassation
jamais une histoire dont on va y revenir
mais que boris johnson s'est en tout cas
on en parle et à l'heure l'homme du bric
site guide pratique de la médecine en
2019 avant de devenir premier ministre
et il a tenu promesse mais à quel prix
c'est la question qu'on va se poser avec
tam
rebond soir minuit
six jours après le référendum qui a vu
les britanniques décidé de quitter
l'union européenne est ce qu'on connaît
le coup cette décision il ya plusieurs
instituts qui se sont essayés à calculer
le coût économique du break site on va
prendre les chiffres de l'office for
budget responsibility espèce de haut
conseil pour les finances publiques
britanniques alors dans ses dernières
estimations des estimations qui date de
mars 2022 ce bureau a estimé que le
break site a coûté 4 % de productivité à
long terme aux britanniques que les
importations et que les exportations ont
baissé de 15% par rapport à la situation
qu'il y aurait eu si le royaume uni
était resté dans l'union européenne et
le pays va perdre quatre points de pib
sur dix ans dont la moitié a déjà été
enregistré donc on n'assiste pas à
l'effondrement de l'économie britannique
ce n'est pas la banqueroute mais c'est
un bilan qui est économiquement un
négatif c'est une érosion qui est à la
fois assez significatives au niveau 1
macroéconomique mais que tous les
britanniques ne sentent pas au quotidien
d'autant que cela est aussi mélanger aux
effets de la pandémie de co vide ou
encore de la guerre en ukraine mais
aussi des métiers des secteurs des
entreprises qui subissent clairement les
effets de là pour le coup c'est très
clair par exemple pour toutes les
entreprises qui exportent vers l'union
européenne la paperasserie nécessaire
pour passer la frontière et niall coûte
cher elle réduit les marges des produits
exportés le résultat c'est que certaines
entreprises qui exportait un petit peu
dans l'union européenne ont tout
simplement arrêté car le jeu n'en valait
pas la chandelle il ya un autre sujet un
majeur et bien c'est celui de la main
d'oeuvre disponible manque de chauffeurs
routiers d'ouvriers agricoles de boucher
un manque de ses revers mais ceux-ci
d'aides-soignants ou d'auxiliaires de
vie on vous allez me dire mathieu c'est
un peu pareil finalement france mais ben
bongo c'est moi voilà bon c'est pas faux
mais le break si tu as encore un peu
plus empirer la situation est d'ailleurs
à la fin de l'année dernière londres a
pris des dispositions pour assouplir sa
politique d'immigration
la politique d'immigration de travail à
allonger la liste des métiers en tension
qui permettent d'obtenir un visa et
quand on se rappelle que l'un des
arguments principaux des propres excite
en 2016 était de limiter l'immigration
en provenance de l'union européenne et
de réserver les emplois aux britanniques
on voit que c'est un petit peu le coup
de l'arroseur arrosé mais c'est pas la
seule promesse des progressistes pas la
seule affirmation des progressistes qui
s'est révélée fausse par la suite non
c'est une campagne à coups aux
exagérations de mensonges qui ont été
vite démentez mais après le résultat du
référendum on se rappelle que boris
johnson avait notamment affirmé que le
royaume uni verser 350 millions de
livres sterling par semaine à l'union
européenne un chiffre qui avait été
inventée qu'il avait promis de reverser
cette somme à la sécurité sociale
britannique en cas de brick site
l'argument avait été placardée sur les
bus de campagne propre excite et puis il
ya aussi la palme du rapprochement
historique sans queue ni tête qui
pourrait être décerné à une déclaration
précise à une déclaration dans le sunday
telegraph où il avait comparé le projet
de l'union européenne à celui d'hitler
je vous cite quand même la phrase
napoléon hitler plusieurs personnes ont
essayé de le faire et cela s'est terminé
de manière tragique
l'union européenne est une autre
tentative avec des méthodes différentes
atteindre donc le point godwin n'est
jamais signe d'une argumentation très
valable et ça pour le coup boris johnson
l'a démontré de façon très probante
merci beaucoup tab ce break 6 et il est
irréversible il est aménageable pour
vous même je pense pas parce qu'en
réalité
il y a eu des sondages est aujourd'hui
56% de la population estime que le break
site ne marche pas beaucoup ne se
prononcent pas et il doit y en avoir 10
9 % qui pensent que ça que ça fonctionne
mais en même temps ça a été un tel
traumatisme pour le royaume uni ces
débats ces cassures dans dans les
familles entre amis que ea non je pense
pas envie de revoir ça en tout cas ça
sera pas le cas sous un gouvernement
conservateur
ça reste populaire jeu les anglais le
président wade bon ça dépend avec qui
vous parlez
je dirais que il ya une meinau vous avez
complètement est mort il ya une fatigue
du mexique qui toujours palpable en
grande bretagne vous avez aussi
non vide ne plus en parler parce que
ceux qui ont voté pour et qui trouve que
ça ne mange pas
ne veux pas en parler parce que ils ont
pas envie d'admettre qu'il a eue ils ont
eu tort ceux qui sont pour le bric si tu
ne veux pas en parler au plus on parlait
parce qu'il veut pas se faire engueuler
parce qu'il est bon là ça marchait pas
et donc on a l'impression que c'est déjà
on a tourné la page et on veut plus
parler du break cm sont le fond je pense
que beaucoup de gens qui se disent mais
ça n'a pas été ce qu on a attendu a
vendu en 2016 on n'a pas le
bénéfice immédiat de ce prêt qui c'est
qui va lui donner le blog aubry sonne
avec les accords on sauve les meubles
ont fait les mêmes accords qu'on avait
avant lorsqu'on mettait membres de
l'union européenne avec certains pays
mais on n'a pas eu la cour qui nous a
été promis avec les états unis
on attend toujours donc il est vrai
qu'il ya certaines personnes qui sont
plus pauvres à cause du brésil et c'est
un sujet un peu tabou en angleterre
maintenant beyond y en a qui se réjouit
en tout cas du départ de mme johnson est
ce qu'on peut parler de soulagement pour
emmanuel macron à ce que c'est que ce
soit emmanuel macron dans les coulisses
du quai d'orsay on ne cache pas une
forme en tout cas de soulagement en tout
cas on salue je cite le départ d'un
partenaire qui est jugé peu fiable il ya
un conseiller d'emmanuel macro qui
misait et quelques jours finalement
donald trump était plus lisible parce
que il ne faisait rien plus ni plus ni
moins qu appliquer son programme qui
était un programme pour celui des
américains du midwest mais au moins
c'était lisible ce qui n'était pas du
tout le cas de boris johnson en fait
entre emmanuelle mercredi boris johnson
ça a été compliqué dès le départ j'ai eu
des moments de tension des moments de
friction les derniers en date rappelez
vous c'était à l'automne dernier sur la
question de la pêche avec les
britanniques qui voulait pas donner les
licences de pêche à nos pêcheurs qui
était pourtant prévu dans l'accord du
breakbeat et boris johnson qui avait
tout fait d'ailleurs pour transformer ce
qui était un désaccord entre la grande
bretagne et l'union européenne en un
bras de fer et une nouvelle guerre
franco britannique ce qui dans les faits
en fait n'était pas le cas des tensions
et des frictions il y en a eu aussi sur
la question de l'immigration et puis a
appelé vous aussi sur la question de
l'alliance au cuss entre l'australie le
royaume-uni et là
ce qui nous avait fait perdre le contrat
le méga contrat avec les sous marins
avec les australiens ce qui est clair
c'est qu'il ya aussi le dossier européen
qui a créé évidemment des tensions avec
le breakbeat et donc que ce soit à
l'elysée ou au quai d'orsay me disais
qu'on espérait trouver un partenaire
juger je cite plus fiables dans les
semaines à venir en langage diplomatique
cela veut dire ce que ça veut dire et ça
s'est jamais garanti sur papier non
c'est pas gagné parce que comme on dit
traditionnellement on sait ce qu'on perd
on sait pas forcément ce qu'on trouve et
c'est vrai que quand on regarde les
débats de ces derniers jours on se rend
compte que les cinq prétendants qui
reste aujourd'hui à la succession de
boris johnson ils ont pas l'air
franchement on va sûrement parler
beaucoup plus tendre ni beaucoup plus
modéré que ce soit sur la question
européenne sur la question de
l'immigration ou sur la question des
finances publiques puisque tous
globalement veulent surtout moins
d'europe évidemment surtout moins
d'immigrés et surtout moins d'impôts
alors vous l'avez dit ils sont cinq à se
disputer la succession de bridge hansen
on va les découvrir ensemble deux grands
favoris liste rush l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères richy sounac
l'ancien ministre des finances l'ancien
ministre de l'égalité qui me bat de
knocked up your gun date est aussi et
puis une outsider penny mordaunt ex
secrétaire d'état au commerce extérieur
et les débats télévisés vous diffusiez
les gens guillon qui sont plutôt tonique
comme en témoigne cet échange c'était
qu'ils aient regardé
ça arrive alors on me dit dans
l'oreillette que ça arrive dans une
seconde c'était un débat hier donc dans
cette primaire interne organisé par le
parti conservateur britannique on
regarde je vous ai entendu le beignet à
la télévision ce matin dire que vous
alliez supprimer l'une de mes règle
selon laquelle le gouvernement ne
devrait pas emprunter pour les dépenses
quotidiennes écoutez c'est une chose
d'emprunté pour des investissements à
long terme mais c'en est une autre de
mettre les factures quotidienne sur la
carte de crédit du pays et nous savons
comment ça finit ce n'est pas seulement
mal c'est dangereux et vous savez quoi
même jérémy corby n'a pas suggéré que
nous allions aussi loin
qu'il ya des favoris enfin je n'ai oui
alors jusqu'à récemment avant les débats
télévisés penny mordaunt était favorite
en effet elle était pratiquement inconnu
du public britannique à l'été ça en est
et restera outsiders non oui plutôt
celle de relater secrétaires d'état peu
de britanniques la connaissent et donc
c'est précisément parce qu'elle était
outsider que les britanniques ont semblé
en tout cas les députés conservateurs
ont semblé apprécier mais certains
disaient jusqu'à la semaine dernière que
c'était la future première ministre le
problème c'est qu'il ya eu des débats
etc au cours des débats eh bien elle n'a
pas été aussi forte aussi bonne qu'on
aurait pu l'espérer et donc ça s'est
recentré sur deux candidats importants
liste ross errishi cenac mais ce que je
trouve à descendre dans l'ensemble de
ces débats c'est que pratiquement des
gens qui ont été tous dans le même
gouvernement pendant des années et c'est
indécent de voir les gens se renvoyer la
responsabilité de tel ou tel politique
on se concentre sur les impôts les
impôts il faut les diminuer alors que
régis nec n'a eu de cesse que de
l'augmenter depuis le 6 juillet est
entrée en vigueur une réforme qui vise à
augmenter les cotisations sociales à et
on dit que c'est contraire à l'héritage
du parti conservateur lee struss
également a sévèrement critiqué donc
richy sonnac et d'ailleurs au dernier
débat que regardez donc dimanche soir on
a vu effectivement que c'était vraiment
une aparté entre les deux est
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que c'est
lors de ces dirigeants n'ont plus de
projets ont parlé du bric si tout à
l'heure mais c'est incroyable c'est
complètement indécent de voir des
candidats en train de nous dire comme
liszt run qu'on va refaire le break site
briques site read hommes et on voit pas
bien ce qu'on pourrait faire de place
qu'il aurait été mal fait par été mal
fait premièrement et deuxièmement on a
entendu une candidate qui n'est plus
dans la course je crois mais même réussi
sonnac syrie je suis siècle a dit qu'il
voulait
démantibulé 2000 loi qui avait été
intégré dans l'ordre interne juridique
interne parce que c'était un héritage de
l'union européenne et qu'on n'en voulait
plus donc une surenchère encore post
break site et tout le monde est sur la
même longueur d'onde et c'est ça qui
effectivement tout à fait intéressant
c'est que je n'ai pas l'impression que
tous ces gens là si vous permettez
l'expression soit sur une autre ligne
politique que celle de boris johnson
vous l'avez dit antibes on excite
anti-européen et anti-immigration
avec son pacte avec ses parts d'ombrés
propres excite anti immigration avec ces
expulsions au rwanda 1 c'est quand même
extraordinaire qui étaient condamnées et
stoppées par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme il ya même des
candidats qui veulent que l'ue le
royaume-uni quitte la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme donc on
voit que je sais qu'ils ont quittée on
quitte boris johnson on est tous le
monde est très heureux de le voir partir
mais je vois là je ne sais pas
finalement si le candidat sera en tout
cas le le responsable le futur premier
ministre conservateur sera mieux que
boris johnson sur l'ensemble des ces de
ces questions politiques c'est lui mais
on nous avait senti des différents
howling entre les candidats non à part
effectivement sur la question des impôts
ou richissime dax se distingue des
autres en souhaitant les augmenter pour
simplement avoir une forme de rigueur
budgétaire les autres sont dans les
promesses habituel on baisse en baisse
les impôts mais ça ressemble à dos et
enfin vos rues pour la diplomatie
française je suis pas sûr parce que en
réalité comme ça a été dit c'est tous
des breaks sitter qui sont dans la
surenchère mais c'est pas étonnant c'est
boris johnson qui les avait choisis et
qui avait expulsé tous les modérés et
les pro-européens du parti conservateur
il y en a 21 dont le petit fils de
winston churchill prépare francophile et
donc il n'ya pas alors il y en a un qui
est marié à une française est en réalité
qui étonne tugend et mai mais qui est
quand même sur une ligne très dur sur
l'ensemble des sujets effectivement
richy sounac qui est arrivé ici un petit
peu par hasard en réalité puisque ça
djidja vide a dû quitter le poste de
chancelier de l'échiquier était moins
connu comme un break sitter virulent
mais effectivement sa décision de
d'effacer tout tous ces règlements qui
sont proches des règlements européens le
finalement va va dans le même sens alors
aussi ce qui va se passer c'est que là
jusqu'à ce que les deux derniers soient
choisis ce sont les députés
conservateurs mais ensuite l'élection ça
va être les membres du parti justement
philippe à ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter un peu comment comment ça va se
passer parce que attention se font
rappeler aux téléspectateurs ce ne sont
pas des élections générales dont c'est
une primaire les élections les élections
internes à l'eau dont le système
parlementaire britannique le parti ce
parti qui lui et quand le portier telus
et le chef de parti qui devient premier
ministre c'est pas le premier ce qui est
élu directement on se fâche l'universel
donc dans le cas actuel de ces
pollutions think is est un parti donc
premier ministre et il s'en va donc y
cherche un nouveau chef de parti
voici les règles en tant que tu peux
changer il fallait que chaque candidat
potentiel est vingt signatures d'autres
députés pour être candidat et ensuite
dans la première ronde des élections il
fallait avoir au moins le soutien de 32
voix pour pouvoir passer au deuxième
tour et donc chaque fois qu'il y à un
nouveau tour c'est le moins
qu'ils disent le moins de voix qu'ils
soient éliminés donc là aujourd'hui il y
aura une nouvelle élection peut-être ici
en soi même ou l'un des cinq candidats
sera éliminé et on arrivait à jusqu'à 2
candidats et ensuite scellé les les
méritants en partie des militants qui
peuvent choisir le gagnant ils sont
combien
donc il ya là il ya quatre candidats
provoqué en or 2 à la fin qui se choisit
que jusqu'au 5 septembre pour
un nom du nouveau premier ministre pour
rester informé min jusqu'à ce qu'on ait
un peu moins de 200 mille militants à
peu près dans les deux sens mais il faut
savoir une chose c'est que le parti
conservateur et organisées de la façon
suivante vous avez la presse de droite
qui le soutien dont le daily mail le sun
et le daily telegraph et le daily
express qui était extrêmement pur au
bike si tu es pro bowl et sturm sonne
vous avez aussi des investisseurs qui
viennent de l'étranger et ben ait lieu
qu'il est trésorier du parti
conservateur à un fonds d'investissement
ou qui attire l'argent des investisseurs
à l'étranger même de la russie qui
investit dans le parti conservateur et
vous avez aussi ensuite les députés
conservateurs qui ce qui représente une
infime partie de la population qui
choisit le presque jusqu'au bout le
prochain un monde du portique sera le
chef du parti et donc premier ministre
et c'est juste à la fin les militants
qui ont dernier mot entre deux candidats
donc au fait démocratiquement on peut se
poser la question est ce que vraiment le
parti conservateur arep raison que les
intérêts des britanniques ou est-ce que
la parti conservateur et représente les
intérêts qui vient de l'étranger les
fonds d'investissements ou l'argent qui
est investi pour d'autres façons en
grande bretagne d'une poignée de
conservateurs guillaume est ce qu'on est
obligé des députés pour devenir premier
ministre alors oui on est obligé de
dettes des élus mmes pour avoir une le
poste de premier ministre et dans les
goupilles à droite vous disais qu'ils
ont fait la campagne pour boris johnson
ils ont fait leur choix parmi les
prétendants
je pense que les choix pas le choix pour
nous c'est plutôt sur which is huningue
qui est le favori
mais c'est parce qu'à la fin ce sera lui
qui gagnera pour ces dispositifs thouars
d'impôts parce que le parti conservateur
depuis toujours c'est une partie qui
propose de réduire les impôts alors que
le parti travailliste c'est le portique
augmente les impôts et donc le fait
corriger sounac et s'attaquer papa les
autres monde dont et des bas en nylon
bichi vous avez l'exemple le plus fort
depuis la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
ça joue contre lui mais il explique je
ne peux pas baisser les impôts parce que
l'argent il faut trouver quelque part je
vais le trouver on en prends ton argent
aux banques et là ça va ramener le pays
dans une position de crise met donc on
comprend sa position mais c'est pas une
position qui est une position de tepic
manquant sa batteur patrick martin genêt
est ce que le la grande bretagne sur le
royaume uni aura tourné la page de
populisme
côté à écouter le discours des candidats
et candidates je n'en suis pas certain
oui on aura tourné la page le populisme
ce que les conservateurs ne seront plus
au pouvoir car lorsque vous entendez le
discours notamment de plus cheap à telle
qu'ils la ministre de l'intérieur qui a
conclu cet accord avec le rwanda pour
expulser tous les
immigrés illégaux même s'ils ne sont pas
au rwanda au rwanda c'est vraiment tout
à fait populiste lorsqu'on voit qu'ils
accusent régulièrement la france 2 pas
contrôler les frontières elle voulait
refouler les embarcations donc dans la
manche qui venait de france et les
autorités portuaires et maritimes ne
refusez ont refusé d'obéir à cette
personne lorsqu'on voit qu'il faut
refaire le break 6 qu'il faut démolir
toute la réglementation européenne et
qu'il faut effectivement plus de
frontières dans l'irlande du nord selon
moi tous les candidats en tout cas sont
encore sur cette même
distance sortie l'époque jones avec le
bouffon de beaux restes y ont besoin de
la comédie etc mais la politique de base
restera le même mason avec les cas notre
durs empreints de changement si on
rappelle que les travaillistes donc pas
gouverné depuis 2010 oui à l'audience
mais les travaillistes aussi est ce qu
est la maladie ne quitte ne reviendrait
pas sur le break site nommé la
rhétorique politique serait un peu
différent exactement sylvie bermann
comment on peut réchauffer faut-il
réchauffer les relations entre la france
et le royaume uni pour terminer c'est
d'abord évidemment il faut attendre de
connaître le successeur il y à des
domaines où il serait important de
renouer cette coopération compte tenu du
fait qu'on a quand même une guerre sur
le continent européen c'est la
coopération très étroite qu'on avait
dans le domaine de la défense et de la
sécurité
en matière de culture en matière de
culture il faut se souvenir que boris
johnson a refusé la proposition
européenne
de
libre circulation des artistes
britanniques et en europe et des
artistes européens au royaume i pour
qu'ensuite liste rose se félicite d'un
accord avec le liechtenstein qui permet
cette libre circulation et donc c'est
difficile cela dit la culture
heureusement ce sont les grandes
institutions britanniques et qui
procède à des échanges avec les français
genre pour terminer un petit tour de
table sur votre favori connexion aux
pronostics c'est difficile sert que pour
le moment c'est effectivement richy
sounac mais on n'a pas de sondages parmi
les électeurs on a les sondages parmi
les parlementaires qui votent jusqu'au
vote éliminatoire mais après patrick oui
moi je pense que liszt reut c'est plutôt
bien parti et la parcours politique très
riche c'est mes affaires étrangères oui
et même pour sa vie personnelle elle a
eu beaucoup de courage on s'habille et
politique dans sa vie personnelle et je
pense que les militants pourrait avoir
une préférence pour elle elle prie
passez un manque de charisme mais je
rejoins un patrick solistes français
pensent qu'elle a probablement un peu
plus de chance d'être élu crise issue
d'un calot korichi siècle est toujours
le favori pour le moment mais c'est pas
le public qui décide un crs et les voilà
prêts guillaume voulez mais on se trompe
quand on fait des pronostics sur la
politique française les pommes faire
prendre le risque de choisir prochain
premier ministre britannique avait très
bien c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à tous d'avoir participé merci à
vous de l'avoir regardé je vous retrouve
demain pour un nouveau numéro sens
public et puis guillaume verdier à
mercredi merci à tous bonne fin de
soirée
[Musique]